ط ط ط طماطم  *****   ط ط ط طماطم
أنا الطماطم يا أطفال *** يعشقني كبار وصغار
وأجبوني لو أسألكم *** فاكهة أنا أم خضار
طماطم طماطم
لا تَخْلُو منِى الوَجَبَاتْ
وغنية بالفيتاميناتْ
اَحْمِى من شَرِّ الأَمْرَاضْ *** مَلِكَةْ أَطْبَاقِ السَّلَطَاتْ
طاااااا طماطم
ومعادن أحوي وألْيَافْ
و معي أبَداً لَنْ تَخَافْ
لَو تَأْكُلَنِي سَوفَ تَصِحْ *** طَعْمِي لَذِيِذٌ لا خلاف
طماطم طماطم
أَحْمِى عِظَامَكَ أَحْمِى الَقلبْ
كي يَنْبِضَ دَوْماً ويُحِبْ
اَجْعَلُ وجْهَكَ نَضِرا مِثْلِى *** تكبر بالعافية تشب
طاااااا طماطم
لَا يَسْتَغْنِى عنِى الطَّاهِي
لَن تَجِدُوا بِالطعم شَبِيِهِي
انا الكاتشب مَا أَطْعَمْنِي *** فَوقَ البيتزا لَونِى زَاهِي
طماطم طماطم
انا الطماطم للأَجْسَامْ
مَطْهُوَة او نَيْئَة طَعامْ
أَصْلُحُ طَازِجَةٌ كَعَصِيرْ *** أنا منعشة يا سلام
طاااااا طماطم
لَونِى أحمر لاَ تَنْسُوُنِي
في المَتْجَرِ دَوْماً تَجِدُونِي
تَحْمِلُنِي ماما للمَطْبَخْ *** ماذا قد تَصَنَعُ مِنْ دُونِي
طماطم طماطم